in my judgment from my practical
experience in the Congress of 25 years
and my two and a half years in the White
House I firmly believe that trying to
put on paper a precise procedure by
which things have to be done in a crisis
is impractical in the first place and
secondly I believe it's unconstitutional
as an undercutting of a president's
responsibility as commander-in-chief of
our military forces and thirdly I would
add and this is probably the most
important point a President of the
United States under any and all
circumstances has to maximize his
efforts either to maintain the peace on
the one hand or to achieve peace on the
other I firmly believe as a practical
matter that the War Powers Resolution
with all its requirements handicaps a
president
from the nation's capital the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research presents public policy forums a
series of programs featuring the
nation's top authorities presenting
their differing views on the vital
issues which confront us
today's topic War Powers and the
Constitution this public policy forum
part of a series presented by the
American Enterprise Institute is
concerned with the war powers of the
Congress and the president the issue is
one our founding fathers preferred after
much debate not to spell out precisely
in the Constitution but which the
Congress in the last three decades has
been determined to interpret and define
our subject War Powers and the
Constitution in broad strokes the
Constitution stipulates that the
Congress shall have the power to declare
war to raise and support armies and to
provide and maintain a navy the
president says the Constitution shall be
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
now interestingly the Constitutional
Convention hammering out the language on
War Powers discussed granting Congress
the power to make war but ultimately and
decided on to declare war again in broad
strokes the War Powers Act of 1973
requires the president one to consult
with the Congress quote in every
possible instance close quote before US
Armed Forces enter hostilities - to
report to the Congress within 48 hours
when forces are so committed and three
to terminate the engagement within sixty
days if Congress has Congress hasn't
declared war or specifically authorized
use of the Armed Forces finally it
allows Congress within those 60 days to
direct the President to withdraw like
resolution passed by both houses which
will not require presidential signature
wherein proof lies the security and best
interest of the United States in the
allocation of War Powers well to chart a
course
out of this dilemma we have a
distinguished panel by far-right
representative Lee H Hamilton Democrat
of Indiana member of the House Foreign
Affairs Committee he also serves on the
permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence to my immediate right
Senator Charles Mathias jr. Republican
and senior senator of Maryland Senator
Mathias is a member of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee and second
ranking member of the Judiciary
Committee to my immediate left
representative Dick Cheney a Republican
of Wyoming mr. Cheney served in the Ford
administration as White House chief of
staff
congressman Cheney was elected to serve
as chairman of the House Republican
policy committee and to my far left
lieutenant general Brent Scowcroft
before retiring for military service in
the Air Force general Scowcroft served
in the White House as President Ford's
national security advisor more recently
general Scowcroft served as chairman of
President Reagan's Commission on
strategic forces
he was also coordinator of AE eyes 1981
project on American vital interests in
regions of conflict now to begin let us
hear first
the views of our 38th president let me
take a particular or a specific example
of what happened under the War Powers
Resolution during my administration I'm
sure people recall the seizure of the
merchant vessel of mayagüez in 1975 when
the Cambodians illegally under
international law seized an American
merchant vessel off the shores of
Cambodia that precipitated of course a
challenge to my administration how could
we get the crew back without any loss of
life how we could recover the ship
itself under the War Powers Resolution
we
would have been hamstrung and
handicapped in trying to go through all
of the procedures which were required we
had to take action and we did and the
net result is the crew and the ship were
recovered from the enemy now that
doesn't mean we didn't sit down and
consult with the Congress we tried to
find them and we were able to have an
opportunity to have them come to the
Cabinet Room and we did tell them what
the facts were we outlined what we were
going to do which was successful members
of Congress have many many other duties
their principal responsibility is not to
be commander-in-chief therefore their
information as to what's transpiring on
a minute by minute or an hour by hour
basis it's not available to them a
president on the other hand where the
Constitution gives him the
responsibility of being
commander-in-chief he has to know by the
hour at least what's happening so he can
act responsibly you can't have 535
commander and Chiefs you can't have 535
secretaries of state their duties under
our Constitution are different different
important but different from the
president and now panel I would post the
same question to each of you in turn has
the world changed so radically in two
hundred years that the Congress should
attempt what our founding fathers were
not willing to do in writing the
Constitution to specifically define and
catalog the prerogatives and powers of
the Congress and the executive in the
exercise of War Powers when you start
Senator Mathias all right would take the
issue I think with the question as it's
framed the authors of the Constitution
made it very clear where the power over
war in peace
would rest it's true that they made the
president commander-in-chief of the
armed forces but they vested the
decision as to war peace solely in the
Congress of the United States they gave
to the Congress the power to make rules
and regulations for the governance of
the Armed Forces they provided that the
Congress should make rules for captures
on land or water so they provided that
the Congress should issue letters of
marque in other words authorizing a
warlike acts by by private vessels so
there is a panoply of power vested in
the Congress by the Constitution which
makes it clear that the the founders
wanted the Congress to control the
issues of war and peace and what the War
Powers Act does is merely to to
implement and in a modern framework what
I feel to be the very clear
constitutional purpose guaranteeing I
would take strong exception John with
the views of my friend and colleague
Senator Mathias I really believe that
the the notion of a declaration of war
is almost an outmoded concept under
virtually any set of circumstances we
can conceive of under which the
president would decide to commit troops
to combat I think in many respects it's
a legacy of the Vietnam War it's a
statute that was adopted in an effort to
keep us out of the next war based upon a
misperception of how we got into the
last one it was put on the books I think
with the expectation that had it been on
the books in 1964 and 65 this nation
would never have been involved in
Southeast Asia I simply don't believe
that that's that's not the case Congress
consistently and continually supported
that adventure and the War Powers Act
hasn't changed that at all
I do believe very firmly that the War
Powers Act is an unwise and and
virtually an unworkable intrusion by the
legislative branch into the powers and
prerogatives that a president needs to
lead the United States and a very
dangerous and hostile world
congressman Hamilton John I support the
War Powers Act
Edwyn Koren the great constitutional
scholar said that the Constitution is an
invitation to the Congress and the
president to struggle for the privilege
of conducting American foreign policy
and I think the War Powers Act simply
reflects that that struggle the purpose
of the War Powers Act is to guarantee
that the Congress and the president will
exercise their collective judgment on
the most important question that
government faces and that is whether or
not you go to war in this day and age
with the extreme complexity of the
modern world the very rapid growth of
America's responsibilities in that world
and the ambiguous nature of so many
international conflicts it seems to me
that kind of a world demands that the
Congress and the president should
exercise their joint judgment their
collective judgment on the critical
question of whether or not you go to war
it's not a decision that ought to be
made by one man or woman even if that
man or woman is the president of the
United States it ought to be a
collective judgment general Scowcroft I
think it's not so much that the world
has changed in two hundred years but the
United States and its role in the world
has changed substantially the
Constitution did not legislate a
government design for maximum efficiency
it legislated a government designed to
protect the rights of the individual
against an overweening government and it
does that very well the problem is that
the inefficiencies that that kind of
freedom protecting innovation dictates
makes it very difficult for a world
power involved in many areas or
everywhere around the world to discharge
its responsibilities the struggle as
congressman Hamilton indicated between
the executive and the legislature has
swung back and forth over our history of
predominance one way or another I think
that in in very practical terms the War
Powers Act is the reflection of a time
when following a series of dynamic and
activist presidents the presidency was
beset both by Vietnam by Watergate and
the Congress in effect seized an
opportunity to make an inroad and to
change the balance that had prevailed
essentially since since Roosevelt I do
believe that we must find ways that the
executive and the legislature can
cooperate in a discharge of the awesome
business of conflict but I think the War
Powers Act in the way it does it in fact
not only ties the hand of the president
but in a sense makes conflict more
likely senator let me say that I agree
with Dick Cheney that the War Powers Act
grew out of the experience of Vietnam I
lived through that as a member of
Congress I voted for the Gulf of Tonkin
Resolution and I think it's fair to say
that most of us who did vote for it felt
in some way finally as the facts were
revealed that we had been bamboozled and
that there was no mechanism no no
process by which the Congress could come
to grips with a situation of that sort
once and the the Act has been done once
the resolution has been passed I
remember once riding in an automobile
with President Johnson and expressing
some doubts about the war and he said
here you voted for this resolution now
if you've got the guts to step up and
and introduce a resolution to repeal it
and he reached in his pocket knee and he
pulled out a copy at one handy
we were we were really without a handle
in which to debate these issues and once
troops are committed and casualties are
being sustained and
of patriotism in the country is up it's
very hard to grab hold of so what the
War Powers Act provides is a mechanism
and a process by which the Congress can
periodically review our involvement in
foreign military adventures and I think
this is entirely consistent with what
the founders of the Constitution
proposed James Madison who probably knew
more about the Constitution than any man
who ever lived once wrote to Thomas
Jefferson that the Constitution supposes
what the history of all governments
demonstrates that the executive is the
branch of power most interested in war
and most prone to it it has accorded me
with studied care vested the question of
war in the legislature Congressman
Cheney but it I would I guess I have to
take exception with Mac I think the War
Powers section with me but you have
trouble taking exception in Madison well
obviously there are differences in terms
of our interpretation of what the
Constitution provides and with respect
to whether the president or the
legislative body has prime authority in
this area and I think most members of
Congress even individuals like myself
who have serious problems of the War
Powers Act believe that that the
language of the Act that talks about
consultation and notification is indeed
perfectly appropriate it's the notion of
Congress being able to move in in a very
short period of time and terminate that
commitment that bothers me a great deal
I look upon the Congress as being all
too often swayed by public opinion of
the moment that there is not a certainty
there are a conviction the kind of
determination or decision-making that
that would let them be an equal partner
with the president with all of the
resources that he has available to him
in terms of making a broad policy
decision that'll hold for a year to for
example of the granadan situation where
the Speaker of the House at the outset
called it gunboat diplomacy and within a
matter of two weeks it changed his mind
and said that indeed
the President Reagan had done exactly
the right thing and sending troops into
Grenada it was right for a time I think
that that Congress unfortunately is a
pretty weak Reid to lead on in terms of
that kind of decision-making I also
would argue Mac that that if the War
Powers Act had been on the books in 1964
when the Tonkin Gulf Resolution was
adopted that it would not have altered
the outcome at all that Congress did
indeed have the opportunity year in and
year out throughout the history of our
involvement in Southeast Asia to reject
the course we were wrong and
consistently year after year after year
appropriated the funds for for that
exercise so I really think it's a bit of
a misreading of history to suggest that
the War Powers Act might have altered
the outcome in Southeast Asia
congressman Hammond I think the real
question is whether the war making power
ought to be a decision rode by one
person or made by the president and the
Congress that seems to me to be the
heart of it and the War Powers Act
simply says that the Congress is going
to participate in that decision why
shouldn't it it seems to me that the
guiding principle is that a democracy
should go to war only with the consent
of the people only with the consent of
the people is expressed by their elected
representatives so I think the War
Powers Act is totally consistent with
the Constitution and with the founding
fathers now general Scowcroft speaks a
moment ago about tying the hand of the
president well quite frankly that's one
of the things we we we we want to do
tying the hands of the president we want
to make the president say to stop to
think to listen before he could submits
us to war that's what we want to do it
is their time instantly when a president
did not consult before committing troops
Wow look what happened in Grenada the
president called in the speaker and the
majority leader at 8 o'clock in the
evening he did not consult with him the
Speaker of the House has said that he
said they were informed that the Marines
were landing at 5:30 the next morning
there wasn't any consultation there it
was just a matter of informing informing
is not consultation at
at eight o'clock the speaker learns
about of it the rest of us learn about
it in the newspaper and the Marines go
in at 5:30 that's not consultation when
Jimmy Carter President Carter sent the
troops into Iran for a rescue mission
he didn't consult with the Congress the
Congress already has adequate resource
it does control the purse strings it
does raise and maintain armies if it
doesn't like what the executive is doing
it has all the power it needs if it can
get itself together to do it that's to
work it's very slow power though it
takes us a long time to do that the
advantage of the War Powers Act is
within the 60-day period or within the
90-day period the Congress has to act to
approve or disapprove it doesn't have to
act that's that is one of the key
problems if it doesn't act by its own
inaction it makes a decision now that it
seems to me is a supine way for the
Congress to work as well but the real
practical effect of the War Powers Act
is in in the real world the president
sometimes has to introduce forces into
an area to try to prevent a conflict to
try to stabilize a region to try to
prevent something from happening in
terms of demonstrating our resolve by
telling our potential opponents that all
they have to do is wait 60 days and see
what happens
you have undercut his ability to
demonstrate that kind of resolve that
could put prevent a conflict for me I
disagree with that general what you've
done is strengthen the decision to
commit the troops if a president commits
troops and he does not have the support
of the Congress and he does not have the
support of the American people he's not
going to be able to sustain that
commitment and he's not going to be able
to keep those troops there we've learned
that lesson very very hard if you're
going to go into war then you would
better be very sure that you've got the
support of the American people if you
don't have the support of the American
people you're not going to be able to
sustain it how do you get the support of
the American people one of the ways is
to have the support of the Congress I
think that me
if I may ask you asked that we focus in
on on Lebanon you played a major part in
a compromise that was worked out the
terms of which were never specific as I
understand it on whether the War Powers
Act was being implemented or not
implemented but it has another peculiar
framework to consider which is that we
were not introducing troops into Lebanon
into hostilities we were a peacekeeping
force which we joined together with
other nations
I think the War Powers Act makes a very
positive contribution to the management
of the Lebanese situation far from
perfect as you point out there's some
ambiguities both in the way the
situation they came about and how we
structured their response but for
example we made it very clear that the
troops on the beach were to be limited
to those who were there who were present
on the day the resolution passed in
terms of numbers in terms of numbers
there are ambiguities about offshore
forces about the the naval forces but
the troops on the beach there was
absolutely no question about that was
totally specific if we go beyond the
number of Marines who were originally
there there has to be real congressional
consultation more than just advice yes
John I understood you correctly you said
that the War Powers Act was not
implemented in the Lebanon situation I
think it was I know what I said was that
there seems to be some confusion about
whether it applied or not or as accepted
as applied by both part now it's very
clear in the resolution that was passed
that section 4 a 1 was implemented in
the resolution that we passed President
Reagan when he signed it did so with the
reservations he obviously had some
questions about it but he did sign it
and this represents the first full use
of the War Powers Act as I understand it
that triggered the 60-day clause that
triggered the 90-day period and now we
have the first president on record as
having implemented the War Powers Act
now he did not accept the war so the
president when he accepted it by signing
the bill
now when he signed the bill he made a
statement about his reservations about
it but the fact is he signed the bill
and it is the law of the land and the
the law specifically triggers the War
Powers Act mr. Hammill Donets that's
like the that's like the veto single
house veto number the president's has
signed numbers and numbers of bills many
presidents have with that in it many
times stating that there is a
constitutional problem that doesn't
wreck doesn't mean that he acquiesce is
it
congressman Cheney the fact John to such
obviously intelligent and bright and
distinguished gentlemen as general
Scowcroft and congressman Hamilton can't
even agree on what we did in the case of
the lebanon resolution strikes me as as
pretty hard evidence that it is a very
difficult piece of legislation and
probably unworkable i think from this
and i would certainly support Brent's
views in terms of what the
administration did also I was fascinated
by the debate on the issue when it came
to the floor of the house because the
debate if I recall had nothing to do
with should we be there or shouldn't we
be there nobody offered an alternative
that said everybody out now the
alternative was it's gonna be 60 days or
90 days or 180 days or 18 months and
often times that the debate over how
many days it should be and whether we
ought to add a month or take a month off
has very little to do with the substance
of policy it has a lot to do with a
posture to my colleagues and whether or
not you can build a majority for six
months instead of nine months I think
it's a bad way to make policy I also
think as Mack pointed out the limitation
on troops on the beach is very unwise if
you're gonna commit military force to a
potentially hostile situation one of the
key ingredients to having it have any
effect at all is the uncertainty that it
creates on the minds of your adversary
and if you have at the outset said yes
we're gonna commit troops but you can't
have any more than 1600 on the beach
under any foreseeable set of
circumstances it seems to me you've
defeated the purpose of having any
troops there in the first place
you said it a two point one this time
factor of course
is not an absolute termination of the
operation the time factor is a period of
time after which the Congress will make
a review and after which there will be
further consultation and as Lee Hamilton
says a joint decision by the Congress
and the executive as to whether or not
the operation shall be continued and
maintained or whether it should be
terminated now it is a it is the point
that never came in Vietnam in a formal
structured way and that's the thing that
was missing in the Vietnam debate the
executive could simply roll over the
Congress the other point that I wanted
to make was this that of course it's
true as dick says that if you say we're
going to get out in a limited period of
time that that may make your adversary
procrastinate and not come to terms with
reality but it also in in the Lebanese
situation could make your friends there
rest on their arms not really engage in
the hard political process of bringing
about a reconciliation of the
conflicting interests within Lebanon
because the longer they keep us there
the longer they don't have to come to
terms with the realities of political
life in Lebanon so I think that there
are two sides to the question of the
uncertainties that are created by a
limited time frame what about the big at
least my view of the big constitutional
question mark which is the right
reserved to the Congress to direct the
President to pullout even in the 60 days
and constitute in effect a legislative
veto of his actions with the Supreme
Court holding certainly in other
circumstances that the legislative veto
is unconstitutional does that bother you
I would have to say that I think that
the decision that the court did hand
down does in fact not bode well for the
legislative veto features of the War
Powers Act and that the War Powers Act
in terms of the provision you cite would
require the president to take an action
by a simple majority vote of both houses
of Congress and
that is indeed a violation of the
separation of powers I basically agree
with dicks observation on it the
provision of the War Powers Act which
permits the Congress to pull out the
troops with a concurrent resolution is
highly suspect now with the Supreme
Court decision and my guess would be
that it's probably unconstitutional
there is a separate bill 'ti clause in
the War Powers Act the likelihood I
think would be that the balance of the
Act might still stand although I might
that may be in dispute as well but I
think dick is quite right in saying that
it's that provision may very well be
unconstitutional
of course that doesn't affect a large
part of the of the War Powers Act the
original statutory 60-day limitation on
the use of troops overseas is not
affected by the Supreme Court decision
that's pristine and untouched the the
provisions on the the growth of forces
or the change of mission or the change
of scope of the mission all that is
untouched by the Supreme Court decision
I don't have any particular color on the
shotted decision but it seems to me
that's only one of several areas where
the constitutionality of the act is no
yes dubious congressman or senator would
you look kindly upon members of the
Congress specifically serving with a
National Security Council and feel that
that would give you something now I I
think that causes real constitutional
precedent problems we we are committed
to the philosophy of separation of
powers and I don't see how you could you
could have that kind of an overlap and I
think that would cause problems
consultation I think I don't find as
much trouble with it is you seem to I do
I think it was entirely proper to call
in the legislative leadership and if the
the the impropriety occurred not in the
people that were chosen in my view but
the fact that they didn't consult
Johnathan's appropriate can we pursue
just for a moment the Scowcroft wanted
to go on go ahead I thought you were
gonna talk about consultation yes I
wanted to follow on with what max said
and
: part mac is is trying to define what
would have been acceptable let's take
Grenada for an example you had a
situation in which the president
believed American lives were at stake
how under those circumstances when the
whole train of events only lasted a few
days from the time the problem arose
until action was taken what would be an
acceptable consultation exactly the
critical decisions were being made down
there on the Golf Course in Atlanta and
tip the speaker plays golf today I mean
if you wanted to really have a
consultation to come down here and play
around the golf with you and he could
join in those conversations that took
place in the clubhouse and on the ninth
hole even with the consultation that the
speaker had and I was present to the
morning of the event when the president
met with a larger group and he had
bipartisan leadership day after the fact
this was at the time that the invasion
was actually underway already there
wasn't one single member in the room of
either party some 30 members of the
House and Senate in the room not one
single memory the room who raised a
question about the operation but three
days later the speaker was out publicly
condemning the president for gunboat
diplomacy and ten days later once he had
all the facts once he had sent a
delegation down to look at what had
happened in Grenada and I asked some
questions came back he said whoops I was
wrong it was indeed a good operation how
do you deal with that kind of situation
if you're the president you're trying to
have some kind of reasonable rational
decision-making process isn't Rene de a
classic example not of a decision to go
to war but rather of a
commander-in-chief to take action to
save American lives and therefore the
War Powers Act probably shouldn't even
apply at all even if we buy your
arguments about what the purpose of the
act is well I don't think so dick my
after all we committed combat troops in
a very major way those combat troops met
resistance they were fired upon we
sustained casualties we had people
killed in war or in the invasion or in
the rescue operation whatever you want
to say now the fact that it turns out
that the American people strongly
supported the action and I think the
Congress strongly supported the action
I don't think is the relevant point here
there was a period of time when the
president was in the process of making
the decision should we go in to Grenada
the question of consultation if you have
the right kind of a spirit prevailing
here it seems to me it would be to
invite congressional leadership in and
no member of Congress could complain I
think if that leadership were the
leadership of the two parties in the
both both houses of the Congress and
restricted only to that group and say
this is what I'm thinking about doing
the important point is prior
consultation the order to invade or to
go in for the rescue had already been
made the president had signed that order
prior to the eight o'clock meeting he
did not call those leaders in to consult
he had already made up his mind to
commit American troops for combat
purposes and he did not consult with the
leaders of Congress if he had consulted
what might have been the outcome well I
don't know but you have to have that you
you have to give the opportunity it
seems to me these are tough questions
maybe the question is not as tough in
the Grenada situation as it would be in
many many others we have the principle
is it seems to me that the the most
important decision that government makes
is whether or not to go to war that is
the paramount decision that government
makes should that decision be made by
one person or should it be made by that
person the president and the Congress
there were people who disagreed strongly
with the executives exercise of War
Powers Act but who did not want the War
Powers Act of 1973 on the grounds that
that gave him powers which were not his
under the Constitution that's thread of
debate ran continuously so that the
suggestion there is is really that why
don't we stay where we are I don't think
the more Powers Act alters the
president's constitutional powers they
are what they are
and the War Powers Act doesn't change
that now that argument is made I grant
you it in private
it's applied most often I think to the
initial 60-day period in which the
president has an open license they say
that the Constitution doesn't give him
any days 60 30 2010 any days and
therefore to say that a president can
act during the 60-day period without
congressional authorization that somehow
it enhances his power I don't think it
does that that was a a device that was
built into the law
I think the War Powers Act doesn't
prevent the president from making
foreign policy decisions it it simply
says that they should be coordinated
with the Congress I certainly agree with
it that there should be consultation and
with the right spirit it can be worked
out probably you know with the right
spirit you don't need the War Powers Act
with the wrong spirit the War Powers Act
really doesn't affect the executive I
mean suppose the president consults as
broadly as you want and the verdict is
that he shouldn't do something there's
nothing that prevents him from going
ahead and doing it that's right so that
for a while for a while but that was
always there it was better in the parent
bird and for the while it seems to me
you get into another clear issue of
constitutionality and that is if if the
role of commander-in-chief does not
include the right to move troops around
then it is an absolute meaningless term
and the Congress irrigates it to itself
by its inaction to force the President
to do something which the Constitution
says he doesn't have to do in other
words to pull the troops out by its own
inaction not even by saying to the
president he shouldn't do that for these
or that or the other reasons but just
because it's unable to make up its own
mind it is forcing the president not to
behave as a four-inch threat it seems to
me is that the war-making powers are
clearly divided in the
Constitution clearly you don't give all
the power to the president you don't
give all the power to the Congress it's
a shared power and that's all we're
trying to say in the War Powers Act when
you make a decision to go to war let's
be sure it's a shared collective
judgment but Lee it was shared before
take the Cooper Church amendments in in
Vietnam the cut off our use of military
forces in Andover Cambodia and so on and
so forth there are many ways for the
Congress to insert in legislation the
kinds of restriction that feels are
important and without an item veto the
president is stopped well I think one
thing we've covered this this subject
very very broadly and I'm sure our
audience I would like to have a chance
to to participate in so I think it's
time for the question and answer session
may I have the first question please yes
my name is John ROM with the faculty at
Clackamas Community College in Oregon
City Oregon my questions for
representative Cheney an event the
Supreme Court would declare the War
Powers Act of 1973 is unconstitutional
due to infringing the president's power
to commit troops what legislative
alternatives would you propose in this
case my own personal view is that we
don't need the War Powers Act if the
court strikes it down I would expect
that it would be on the basis of the
provision that we discussed up here
earlier that is to say that it's
constitutes a legislative veto the
president doesn't have the opportunity
himself to veto that act by that
Congress and therefore it violates the
separation of powers I think as Mac and
Lee and Brent of all said that the the
heart of having the relationship work
between the president and the and the
executive branch and the executive
branch and the Congress in this area is
basically a requirement for good-faith
effort on both sides and my own personal
view is that Congress already has
adequate restrictions and restraints and
powers and authority on the book on the
books so that they are in a position to
be able to intervene if a president does
make a serious mistake they do have the
power of the purse they do have the
opportunity to hold hearings and and
conduct oversight investigations and and
decide whether or not Congress wants to
sustain that effort after the
fact but that in the 1980s and the in
the years ahead
we're very unlikely to find ourselves in
a set of circumstances where the kind of
conflict that is envisioned in the War
Powers Act is likely to arise and that
presidents have to be trusted to some
extent that once they're elected we
delegate to them enormous authority
directly and indirectly we build nuclear
weapons systems and we'd give them total
control over those system without
consultation with the United States
Congress whatsoever and it seems to me
having made that leap of faith that we
are in fact going to trust the president
to be commander in chief under those
circumstances we can also trust him in
other areas and that there's no need for
a replacement if you will for the War
Powers Act should that be struck down
I think there is a subjective value to
the War Powers Act that perhaps hasn't
been sufficiently appreciated during the
the debate in which it was first adopted
senator Javits he used to say that it
was like a sign at a railroad crossing
that it was simply saying stop look and
listen before you embark on this journey
overseas and I think that that's the
effect that we hoped it would have on
the executive branch but there is a
subjective effect on the legislative
branch which is not without some
importance and and that is that in a in
a non adversarial way it provides a
framework in which you can examine an
operation you know when when I
introduced the resolution I think it was
in 1969 to repeal the Gulf of Tonkin
Resolution finally took up Lyndon
Johnson's challenge that was in fact an
adversarial action but the kind of
periodic reviews that are provided in
the War Powers Act don't have to be
adversarial they people will take sides
within the debate but the existence of
the debate itself becomes a matter of
procedure and and is is neutral as to
the event I would like to suggest that
that that is not the way it is viewed by
the executive branch that it is an
irritant to the executive branch and
considered broadly a congressional
attempt to infringe on the prerogatives
of the president and in fact it present
prevents the kind of free well
cooperative consultation which i think
is the fundamentally real answer to our
private I must say I you know I come
back to the basic notion Mack that I
don't think we can find an example in
modern times when a president hasn't
done what the War Powers Act expects him
to do anyway to the extent that we talk
about consultation and notification I
don't know of anybody who served in the
presidency in the last 30 or 40 or 50
years and probably longer than that if I
thought went back far enough who would
have made a decision in an high-handed
arrogant fashion to commit troops in a
way that ultimately lacked the kind of
public support broad public support that
it requires certainly that wasn't Lyndon
Johnson's intent when he got involved in
Southeast Asia certainly that wasn't the
congressional intent when they supported
it in the end
public opinion swung against it but it
took years of developments and and
gradual constant escalation of of our
involvement there but there's nothing
than the War Powers Act had it been in
place in 1964-65 that it would change
that and I think I think we do have to
rely to some extent on good-faith
interpretation of our responsibilities
both as legislators and executives and I
think that history would bear out the
statement that in fact that good-faith
effort has been there in virtually every
case so one of the premises in which
we're meeting is to discuss
constitutionality and therefore I drag
you back to the history of the
Constitution which you say which I think
is pertinent the executive side of this
argument is presented as the need to
reposed confidence in the judgment of
the president and his advisors Alexander
Hamilton was never thought to be soft on
the executive he was always viewed as a
strong executive advocate
what he said in writing the Federalist
Papers that the history of human conduct
does not warrant that exalted opinion of
human virtue which would make it wise in
a nation to commit interests of so
delicate and momentous akan as those
which concern intercourse with the rest
of the world to the sole disposal of a
magistrate created in circumstance as
would be a President of the United
States and I think there is a is a kind
of concern expressed at the very birth
of the Republic that reflects the
problems that we are discussing here
this evening I would agree with that but
I think you know to imagine that that
the world is different and therefore the
framers in a sense didn't know what they
were doing or what have you is wrong
there's been a recent study that about
10 percent of the military engagements
between 1780 and 1880 were consequent to
a declaration of war that is around the
world so that so the idea that that
undeclared wars are a recent phenomenon
the degree is that for sure the degree
is different but the circumstances are
pretty standard but you know in the
process of writing the Constitution as I
think I can't remember who said it now
you know the words to make war were
deliberately changed to declare war now
that cannot have been accidental it
wasn't accidental it was a result of
debate and it seems to me that that's a
very important change one is in a sense
recognizing a situation if you will the
other is initiating establish who was
there argues that that that the power
there was not vested solely in the
president and should not have it is not
and should not him and it is not because
the Congress raises and maintains armies
well we have to get another question is
do somebody your next are you sir yes
sir
Robert Goldwyn director of
constitutional studies of American
Enterprise Institute Senator Mathias
that passage from Alexander Hamilton you
just quoted was in reference not to
making war or declaring war but in
reference to the power the
constitutional advice and consent on
treaties and I think that raises an
interesting question related to what
congressman Hamilton was was saying
about bringing Congress into the
decision-making do you mean some kind of
consenting role in the in the same sense
as advise and consent with regard to
treaties that is would you really try to
restrict the power of the President to
the extent that if when he did consult
with members of Congress and they gave
him opposing advice or conflicting
advice as congressmen and Senators a
want to do that is they disagree among
themselves then what does the president
do do you do you really mean that the
congressman should have some role in the
decision-making power because that then
puts in real question the whole
principle of separation of powers I
think we made that clear in reference to
general Scowcroft
question about whether members of the
legislative branch should should serve
on the National Security Council I think
that clearly would be a violation of
separation of powers and under the
American Constitution as we know it
today it wouldn't be proper and I'm not
suggesting that I think what Hamilton
was looking at was foreign policy and
war is of course the ultimate extension
foreign-policy the ultimate act of
foreign policy and so I think it's
clearly comprehended within within his
thinking it seems to me that what we're
saying is that there must be a
coordinate decision made now I don't see
how we can ever embody in a statute
precisely how this will occur Lee
Hamilton has one kind of personality
Dick Cheney has a kind of personality
there will be presidents with which one
of them will be simpatico and presidents
which the other one will not and these
human factors get into the act general
Scowcroft and and Dick Cheney and both
having served in the highest positions
in the White House know how
personalities have become important
elements of policymaking and decision
execution but I think that's one reason
that it's impossible to create an
absolutely rigid hidebound system of
consultation that from administration to
administration it's going to change a
little bit but I think the factor is
that you that that the president be
exposed to all the considerations before
the dishes before the decision is made
you ask should the Congress consent why
shouldn't the Congress consent
what's wrong in a democracy by making a
judgment in a democratic manner that's
all we're asking are you saying that
that the consent should be mandatory on
the present finding on others the
question was should the Congress consent
to the decision and I I see nothing
wrong with the Congress consenting again
Lee we come back to the proposition that
most of the times when military force
has been used in recent years simply
haven't been circumstances which led
so it's like that kind of what kind of a
war can the President of the United
States carry out if the Congress of the
United States doesn't consent but in in
many respects again we've already given
prior approval in a sense we have
appropriated the funds and raised the
army and purchased the equipment and and
built the missiles and the bombers and
said okay here now you have you have the
authority to make decisions about how
we're going to use certain elements of
that to suggest that that you can go to
the Congress and and involve the
Congress as deeply as I think you you
would like to in the decision in advance
of the actual commitment of troops to
strikes me is not very practical I have
I simply have to raise the caveat that
the existence of the defense
establishment is in some way an
authorization to the President to start
out on foreign adventures
I I don't believe that it's a
recognition that we live in a dangerous
and hostile world and from time to time
we may have to defend ourselves and
defend our interest and that the
individual we look to to make those
decisions especially those that that
take on the nature of a decision of a
commander-in-chief rather than a
legislative body we entrust to the
president but but I think it's Brent
Scowcroft who said we we entrust that
final decision of the president but we
have confidence that Secretary of State
will have his say that the Secretary of
Defense will have some comment that the
Joint Chiefs of Staff will talk about
the military feasibility that the
central intelligence agency will provide
basic information that that the whole
operators of government will be brought
to bear now at some point in that
decision-making process and and I
certainly would not have meant to imply
that guide I thought that this is
something the president besides in the
shower bath on his own that that
somewhere in this process there is room
and time to to register the
congressional point of view I think you
have to draw a distinction between two
situations one is the emergency
situation dick you refer to that awful
frequently and I I think
you're probably correct in that there
are going to be times when a president
has to act arguably that was Grenada the
American citizens had to be rescued
right now and the president really
didn't have time I can see how you can
make a case for the president moving
very quickly on that but that's not the
only time a president is or the only
manner in which a president is going to
be confronted with the decision to
commit troops should we invade Nicaragua
today that's a possible question on the
agenda of the of the country if I were a
president reflecting on that question
today I'd like to call Mac Mathias and
talk with him about it and talk with
some others about it too and that's what
we're saying and it seems to me that
kind of a situation is is very different
from the emergency situation but I think
I think we need to be clear about
another thing and that is a War Powers
Act does not say the president will not
attack this or that or the other it
really says the president may not move
troops that's what it's talking about
may not introduce troops in certain
areas it seems to me that is fundamental
certain circumstances in which
hostilities are in that's right but it
is but it's back to to dick's point
about having raised armies what cannot
what can the president do with them and
it seems to me that if the
commander-in-chief cannot deploy and
move his forces around then the term
commander-in-chief is absolutely
meaningless and it's not we're not
talking about specifically going to war
here there is nothing about that in the
War Powers Act we're talking about
hostilities and that is in the world
where it is possible we're not talking
about the president using forces
offensively deliberately to attack all
right next question please who has the
microphone that we get to microphone
email I'm Terry Emerson counsel to
Senator Barry Goldwater who voted
against the War Powers Resolution I I
make a quick comment on Alexander
Hamilton because I read his works in a
famous set of written debates with James
Madison Hamilton did make a clear
distinction between
offensive war and defensive war he said
the Congress can commence offensive war
through the declaration power but the
president possesses the defensive power
to initiate defensive actions on behalf
of the United States my question to the
panel would be to any member who would
wish to make a test of the War Powers
Resolution against the history
immediately preceding World War two take
the actions of President Franklin
Roosevelt in 1941 in 1940 Congress had
barely renewed the military draft by a
single vote yet in 1941 President
Roosevelt before any declaration of war
sent American Marines equipped for
combat
- both Greenland and Iceland he gave
them orders to cooperate fully with
British armed forces who were already
there defending the islands against Nazi
Germany
Franklin Roosevelt also ordered the
American Navy to escort British shipping
in the North Atlantic and to shoot on
sight against German u-boats all this
before any declaration of war under the
War Powers Resolution Congress would
have been faced with having to vote
within 60 days on whether to extend
President Roosevelt's powers I asked
whether testing the War Powers
Resolution in this situation would not
have led to a total disaster for the
democracies of the world through an
isolationist Congress refusing to ratify
President Roosevelt's wise actions who
would like to start I'll simply say that
the gentlemen I think state of the case
eloquently and he's absolutely right sir
well I think it's only a hypothetical
judgment is what might have happened if
the War Powers Act had been in effect it
is it is so difficult to project it it's
true for just just by way of example how
unpredictable history is
it's true that senator goldwater voted
against the War Powers Resolution but
thereafter he called for the immediate
withdrawal of the Marines from Lebanon
so I I don't know what real conclusions
you can draw this concludes another
public policy forum presented by the
American Enterprise Institute for Public
Policy Research on behalf of AEI our
hearty thanks to the distinguished and
expert panelists representative Lee H
Hamilton Senator Charles Mathias jr.
representative Richard Cheney Lieutenant
General Brent Scowcroft and also our
thanks to our guests and experts in the
audience for their participation goodbye
from Washington
it is the aim of AEI to clarify issues
of the day by presenting many viewpoints
in the hope that by doing so those who
wish to learn about the decision-making
process will benefit from such a free
exchange of informed and enlightened
opinion
this public policy forum series is
created and supplied to this station as
a public service by the American
Enterprise Institute Washington DC
kei is a nonprofit nonpartisan publicly
supported research and education
organization
[Music]
for a transcript of this program send
$3.75 to the American Enterprise
Institute 11:50 17th Street Northwest
Washington DC - 0 0 3 6
[Music]
you